- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is practice squaring binomials,
and this is something
that we've done in the
past, but we're gonna do it
with slightly more involved expressions.
But let's just start with
a little bit of review.
If I were to ask you,
what is a plus b squared,
what would that be?
Pause the video and try to figure it out.
Well some of you might immediately know
what a binomial like this
squared is, but I'll work it out.
So this is the same thing
as a plus b times a plus b.
And then we could multiply
this a times that a.
So that's going to give us a squared.
And then I can multiply
that a times that b,
and that's going to give us ab.
Then I could multiply this b times that a.
I could write that as ba or ab,
so I'll just write it as ab again.
And then I multiply this b times that b,
so plus b squared.
And what I really just did
is apply the distributive property twice.
We go into a lot of
detail in previous videos.
Some people also like to
call it the FOIL method.
Either way, this should all be a review.
If it's not, I encourage you to look
at those introductory videos.
But this is going to simplify to a squared
plus we have an ab and another ab,
so you add those together,
you get two ab plus b squared.
Now why did I go through this review?
Well now we can use this
idea that a plus b squared
is equal to a squared
plus two ab plus b squared
to tackle things
that at least look a
little bit more involved.
So if I were to ask you,
what is five x to the sixth
plus four squared,
pause this video and try
to figure it out.
And try to keep this and this in mind.
Well there is several ways
you could approach this.
You could just expand this
out the way we just did,
or you could recognize this pattern
that we just established.
That if I have an a
plus b and I square it,
it's going to be this.
And so what you might notice is,
the role of a is being
played by five x to the sixth
right over there, and the role
of b is being played by four
right over there.
So we could say, hey, this
is going to be equal to
a squared, we have our a squared there.
So what is a squared?
Well five x to the sixth squared is going
to be 25 x to the 12th power.
And then it's going to be
plus two times a times b.
So plus two times five x
to the sixth times four.
Actually let me just write it out
just so we don't confuse ourselves.
Two times five x to the,
I'll color code it too,
two times five x to the
sixth times four, times four,
plus b squared.
So plus four squared, so
that's going to be plus 16.
And then we can simplify this.
So this is going to be
equal to 25 x to the 12th.
Two times five times four is 40.
Two times five is 10 times four is 40.
So plus 40 x to the sixth plus 16.
Let's do another example.
And I'll do this one
even a little bit faster,
just because we're getting,
I think, pretty good at this.
So let's say we're trying to determine
what three t squared
minus seven t to the
sixth power squared is.
Pause the video and try to figure it out.
All right we're going
to do it together now.
So this is our a, and
our b now we should view
as negative seven t to the sixth.
Because this says plus b, so
you could view this as plus
negative seven t to the sixth.
We could even write that if we wanted.
We could write this plus
negative seven t to the sixth
if it helps us recognize
this whole thing as b.
So this is going to be equal to a squared,
which is nine t to the fourth,
plus two times this times this,
two times a times b.
So two times three t squared
is going to be six t squared
times negative seven t to the sixth.
Actually let me write this out.
This is getting a little bit complicated.
So this is going to be plus
two times three t squared
times negative seven t to the sixth power.
And then last but not
least, we're going to square
negative seven t to the sixth.
So that's going to be negative
seven squared is positive 49,
and t to the sixth
squared is t to the 12th,
t to the 12th power.
And so this is going to be
equal to nine t to the fourth,
and let's see, two times three is six
times negative seven is negative 42,
and t squared times t to the
sixth, we add the exponents,
we have the same base, so it's
going to be t to the eighth.
And then we have plus
49 t to the 12th power.
So it looks like we did
something really fancy.
We have this higher degree polynomial.
We were squaring this binomial that has
these higher degree terms.
But we're really just
applying the same idea
that we learned many many many videos ago,
many many lessons ago, in terms
of just squaring binomials.